فال اسمحوا لي أن أتطرق إلى ما كان
يقوله مينا قبل الاستراحة مباشرة وهو
أه أنت تعلم أن واشنطن سمحت لهذه
الميليشيات أه تنمو حزب الله بدأ في
الحرب اللبنانية في الثمانينات ولكن حماس
ثم الهويس ثم تلك الميليشيات في
العراق وفي سوريا  أم كلهم ​​مدعومين
وممولين من إيران ما هي أفضل
استراتيجية ديفيد سانجر في النيويورك
تايمز اليوم لديه مقال تحليلي
أعتقد أنه مثير للاهتمام للغاية
حيث يقول أه ضرب إيران بقوة
لم يثبت أنه يردعهم أه
يشير  أن اغتيال سواني
القائد الإيراني لم يردع
إيران حقًا كما نرى الآن أه لكن
التفاوض معهم في بعض الأحيان كان له
تأثير مؤقت على الأقل في
إيقاف
الأنشطة الإيرانية، كيف تعتقد أنه يجب على الولايات المتحدة أن
تتعامل مع هذه القضية للحصول على
هذه
أعتقد أن ديفيد على حق،
بمعنى أنه عندما قتلت الولايات المتحدة
سليماني، ردت إيران
بأكبر
هجوم صاروخي واجهته القوات الأمريكية على
الإطلاق، وكان من
حسن الحظ أنه في  تلك النقطة التي
لم تتركها أدت إلى حرب أكبر بكثير، ومن
الصحيح أيضًا أنه
قبل السادس من أكتوبر،
توصلت الولايات المتحدة وإيران بطريقة ما إلى طريقة عمل
دفعت
مستشار الأمن القومي إلى الاعتقاد بأنك
الشرق الأوسط كان في أكثر
أوقاته سلمية أه على مدى أكثر من عقد من الزمان
ولكننا حيث نحن
والمعضلة التي تواجهها الولايات المتحدة هي
أن حرب غزة أصبحت سببا في
تصعيد هذه الهجمات
لأسباب ذكرها مينا أن
ترى هذه المجموعات ميزة أو
فرصة في اتباع
سلوك أكثر عدوانية، مما يفرض ضغوطًا على
إسرائيل والولايات المتحدة، لذا تواجه الولايات المتحدة
معضلة تحتاج إليها لإنهاء هذه
المياه، والتوصل إلى وقف لإطلاق النار لأنه في
المرة الأخيرة التي حصلنا فيها على اتفاق.  كان وقف إطلاق النار لمدة 8 أيام
هو المرة الوحيدة التي صمتت فيها جميع الأسلحة
في الشرق الأوسط، ولكن إذا
كان لديك وقف لإطلاق النار في هذه اللحظة ساري
المفعول، فستفوز حماس وإيران وحزب الله
بالطريقة التي أوضحها كندري كيسنجر
من ناحية أخرى، إذا فعلت ذلك  إذا
لم يكن هناك وقف لإطلاق النار، فإن الولايات المتحدة
تواجه خطرًا جديًا بأن ينتهي بها الأمر
في مواجهة مباشرة مع إيران
أو الميليشيات الشيعية في العراق أو كل ثلاثة
منهم في نفس الوقت، لذلك أعتقد أنه
يتعين على الولايات المتحدة أن تختار أه
ذلك  هل تريد أن تتخذ
الخطوة الأولى على الأقل للتوصل إلى وقف إطلاق النار
لتهدئة المنطقة ثم التفكير
في استراتيجية أوسع نطاقًا بكثير لما
ستفعله بشأن الحوثيين
والميليشيات الشيعية وإيران أم أنها
ستفعل ذلك؟  تنتهج سياسة محاولة
ترهيبهم والمخاطرة الكبيرة
بأن ينتهي بهم الأمر إلى حرب أه
ويمكن أن يخطئ الطرفان في الحسابات في لحظة كهذه
أه مينا ما رأيك أن
عرب الخليج الإمارات العربية المتحدة
السعوديين أه ال  سيرغب البحرينيون في ذلك
لأنهم يعرفون مرة أخرى أن لديهم
هذه المعضلة وهي أنهم لا
يحبون إيران، لكن الإيرانيين يستغلون الآن
القضية الفلسطينية وحرب غزة،
وأعتقد أنهم ينظرون إليهم على أنهم أكثر من
الأبطال.  من ذلك السبب أه
عرب الغول صامتون إلى حد كبير كان هناك
بعض الإدانة لكن البيوت هم من
يطلقون الصواريخ حزب الله هو
الذي يطلق الصواريخ
ويدعون باسم القضية الفلسطينية
حسنا يعني حزب الله والبيوت
يريدون ذلك والميليشيات  في العراق يريدون أن يكون
هذا هو السرد القائل إن
الطريقة التي تدعم بها الفلسطينيين في الواقع هي
إطلاق الصواريخ هنا وهناك
بدلاً من بذل جهد متضافر
للحصول على الاعتراف بالدولة
الفلسطينية، وهو ما تمثله
الجامعة العربية والمملكة العربية السعودية وما
تعمل دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة وآخرون على تحقيق ذلك،
لذلك أعتقد أنه من المهم حقًا في
الإطار أن نفكر في ماهية النجاح وما
نريده، وفي النهاية يجب أن
تكون هناك دولة فلسطينية من شأنها أن تنهي
الكثير مما نراه الآن الذي
حققته الولايات المتحدة.  بدأ البرنامج
بالقول إن الولايات المتحدة تريد
الخروج من الشرق الأوسط، الواقع هو أن الولايات المتحدة
متواجدة في الشرق
الأوسط وتتدخل لإطالة أمد
حروب أو صراعات معينة دون إنهائها
أو اتخاذ حل نهائي لها
لذلك نحن'  سأعطي مثالا عندما يتعلق الأمر
بإسرائيل وفلسطين بدون حق
النقض الأمريكي، كان من المحتمل أن
تكون هناك دعوة من الأمم المتحدة لوقف إطلاق النار
الذي كان سيكون ملزما، ومع ذلك فإن
الولايات المتحدة هي التي تستخدم
حق النقض، لذا فهي تشارك بالمثل عندما نقوم بذلك.
أحد
الإجراءات الأولى التي اتخذتها إدارة بايدن
هو إزالة الهويس من
التصنيف الإرهابي الذي كان لديهم بسبب
الضرائب التي قاموا بها في
المنطقة، وبالتالي أعطى هذا
الانطباع بأنه لا بأس بالنسبة لهم أن
يستمروا وأن  القائمة تطول، الولايات المتحدة
متورطة بما يكفي في نهاية المطاف لإضعاف
هذه الميليشيات، فأنت بحاجة إلى دول قومية
تعمل، العراق، لبنان، اليمن، سوريا،
وقد سمح ضعفها لإيران
بتوسيع قوتها ونفوذها، وهو
أحد الأشياء الرئيسية التي أرادت إيران أن تكون
قادرة على إنشائها في المنطقة.  يجب أن يكون للمنطقة
حدود برية وسيطرة تمتد من
إيران على طول الطريق إلى حزب الله، بحيث تمر
عبر العراق مروراً بسوريا
إلى لبنان، ولذلك عملت لسنوات
على هذا الأمر وتستمر في ممارسة
نفوذها ما نراه على
الأرض  وفي اليومين الماضيين أيضًا،
رأيت قادة الميليشيات هؤلاء يظهرون في
بغداد ليقولوا إننا مازلنا هنا باسم
موصل من كان لواء أو اللواء الذي
استهدفه الأمريكيون في
ضرباتهم على العراق، وكان آخرها هناك
علنًا  في المستشفيات لأقول
إنني أستطيع أن أتجول دون حصانة من العقاب،
مع الإفلات الكامل من العقاب في العراق، إذا كان لديك
دول قومية قوية
تحاسب قادة الميليشيات، فسنجري
محادثة مختلفة بدلاً
من انتظار الضربات الجوية التي
لا تؤدي حقًا إلى  إن الحل بمفرده هو
عمل شاق ولكنك بحاجة إلى دول أقوى